[Musique]
le président n'a rien prévu
il savait depuis février combien c'était
grave il savait que c'était une maladie
mortelle et qu'at-il fait les leaders
nous avons fait un super boulot
les seuls à dire le contraire ce sont
les faits qu news le virus ne va pas
disparaître du jour au lendemain donc il
faut que nous habitions à vivre avec ce
virus à nous remettre à consommer à
travailler normalement ou buvette à
l'assemblée nationale julien buvette qui
est soumise comme tous les bars à paris
en ce moment à la fermeture à 22 ans et
que disent les députés
on peut se demander pourquoi tout d'un
coup elle est fermée et pourquoi ce
serait il y aurait plus de risques qu'on
soit contaminée à 21h30
en sortant de séance qu'à 22h30 en
surconfiance vous avez dit que vous êtes
allé à delaware state mais vous avez
oublié le nom de votre université vous
n'est pas allé à delaware state vous
avez un diplôme quasiment dernier de la
classe donc te parlais pas
d'intelligence avec moi n'utilisez
jamais le mot intelligence avec moi
parce que il n'ya rien d'intelligent
chez vous qui va la buvette à 22h entre
nous pas grand monde c'est uniquement
quand il ya des séances de nuit non mais
expliquez moi en quoi quelqu'un est plus
contagieux après 22 heures et avant 22
heures
tout ça est grotesque il ya une
incertitude économique très très forte
on parle des grandes entreprises qui
évidemment vivent des suppressions
d'emplois des anneaux suppressions
d'emplois il ya toutes les petites
entreprises via un plan social massif
qui en train de s'opérer un peu partout
dans le pays
le fait est que je me suis retrouvé face
à face avec poutine et je lui ai fait
comprendre que nous n'allions prendre
aucune de ces affaires c'est le petit
chien de poutine et bars et les
restaurants fermés depuis dimanche ont
gardé leurs rideaux baissés
le tribunal administratif de marseille a
débouté les restaurateurs qui avaient
saisi la justice pour suspendre l'arrêté
pris par la préfecture pour une période
de 15 jours au milieu de la cacophonie
je baille dollars
chez nous c'est dur de parler avec ce
cône parce que ils veulent simplement
pouvoir travailler mais on nous faire
nos établissements dans les punitions
collectives jamais supporté que ce soit
à l'école ou dans d'autres dispositifs
là bas on impose à tous les
restaurateurs à tous les bas mais ceux
qui respectent pourquoi les fermer si la
décision n'est pas prise on se
retournera vers clients se retournera
vers l'état en disant qu'il est a été
défaillant et donc on n'a pas d'autre
choix au moment que d'avoir des mesures
sanitaires strictes ça fait plaisir à
personne de prononcer la fermeture
administrative d'un bar ou d'un
restaurant et jeudi le ministre de la
santé et les membres du gouvernement
compétent auront à s'exprimer pour comme
chaque semaine et comme je les dis
annoncer les décisions prises et les
ajustements
chaque semaine le gouvernement doit
pouvoir prendre des mesures
additionnelles nécessaires en fonction
de l'évolution de l'épidémie et chaque
mesure prise un temps de vie de 15 jours
parce que c'est le temps qui permet de
voir son efficacité
ces deux photographes de mayenne ont
trouvé une solution pour faire cette
photo de classe sans masque regardez le
résultat mettre les enfants dans des
boîtes et ensuite réalisé ce montage où
on retrouve toute la classe messieurs je
déteste élever la voix
mais pourquoi devrais-je faire autrement
que vous je pense que le pays serait
mieux servie si vous vous interrompirent
moins tous les deux semaine dernière
nous étions avec edouard philippe ou
havre dans sa belle ville et de ce point
de vue là moi je me réjouis de discuter
aujourd'hui avec anne hidalgo
je rejoins aussi de morphine viens de
dire edouard je savais exactement dans
le sens de ce que disait edouard
philippe a totalement raison
cette information qui concerne les
habitants du grand paris qui ont été
surpris par une grande explosion
survenue à 11h56 il s'agissait en fait
d'un avion de chasse qui a franchi le
mur du son
un rafale de la base de saint-dizier
comme celui ci qui a dû décoller en
urgence pour porter secours à un avion
civil en perte de contact et qui depuis
ma bien pourquoi vous avez rien fait
depuis ces 25 dernières années parce que
votre présidence a tout bouleversé vous
hais
les sénateurs être le pire président que
l'amérique ait jamais connu le bout si
subjectif et je le vois bien dans le
regard de ma femme